cependant dans paris la vie continue
plutôt la guiraud commence
les premiers jours de la libération 3
semblent tous les dimanches qui serait
un peu des 14 juillet
en l'absence de métro les parisiens ont
réinventé des autobus de fortune voir
ressusciter les vieux omnibus d'âge pour
depuis un mois les disciples est ont
fait dépouiller les agents ont retrouvé
leurs gestes rituels mais nous ferons
plus circuler que des cyclistes
le vélo stop à remplacer locaux stop
les plus ingénieux ont trouvé de
nouveaux moyens de se déplacer sans
charbon ni essence
l'armée américaine est prise en charge
par les parisiens